this video is sponsored by fabulous
let's go visit beautiful Prague where
Exquisite historical buildings surround
the urban freeways and parking lots the
powder Tower the main railway station
the National Museum New Town Old Town
the castle District the state Opera it
was a fun day in the evening after
picking up your asthma medication time
to get some rest but where will you stay
the night you could go to a hotel but
that's very unepic are you kidding let's
go to somewhere more contemporary a
short-term rental Airbnb it's a
SmartPhone based service where
homeowners can let their property out to
tourists for a few nights will you be
gone for a week or two and there's no
one to take care of the apartment well
now you can get someone and make money
in the process everybody wins so you
download the app and PK cute studio
apartment in the proc Center a guy
called Peter from Prague is coming to
meet you to show you around his place
he's standing in front of you inviting
you through the entrance gate there is
just one problem Peter from Prague
doesn't exist
[Music]
what but he's standing right in front of
you did your mental health decline
suddenly No in fact your mental health
is easier than ever to maintain with the
help of today's sponsor fabulous
fabulous as your digital coach and
happiness trainer in your pocket helping
you achieve your goals and build better
habits it helps me preserve my mental
health as I read through some of the
questions people ask me via email based
on Behavioral Science fabulous helps you
develop great healthy habits to make
your life more fulfilling and productive
the app will help you create your own
rituals through the day these small
steps that lead to big changes the two
main ways to use the app are happy
tracking and dedicated programs in habit
tracking you can choose from more than
100 recommended habits or you can create
your own fabulous then helps you build
these habits through Behavioral Science
and gentle reminders dedicated programs
will help you achieve your well-being
goals over several weeks any new habits
you pick up in the process can be added
to your daily routine if you serve
choose personally my favorite part of
fabulous are the beautiful visuals aside
from the fact that its methods actually
work with the premium version you can
build and improve an unlimited number of
habits in your routines and have access
to all programs and exercises start
building your daily routine the first
500 people to click the link below will
get 25 of their fabulous subscription
thank you for checking out fabulous ads
like this helps support what I do and
now back to the video Peter from Prague
is standing by the gate a pair of dull
listless eyes inspect here as you drag
your luggage closer he greets you with a
forced smile drafted into his face by
Powers Beyond his control Peter from
Prague doesn't exist he is not letting
out anything of his to you he doesn't
even own an apartment and yet there is
dense the Prague Center is an extremely
busy Place throughout the year there are
so many people it's often impossible to
move chock full squares hordes of people
flowing down narrow streets idyllic
paintings of Charles bridge with a dozen
people strolling around or just a
reminder of a bygone era before over
tourism until one day I was shocked to
find Charles bridge almost completely
empty perhaps for the first time in
decades barely a soul on the bridge
moving on to the center it was more the
same deserted streets closed stores and
restaurants empty squares just a few
cores thrown here and there motionless
even Old Town Square a place where it's
often physically impossible to move to
the pendant it was November 2020 kovit
measures were in effect but those
measures alone wouldn't cause the city
center to empty out like that I've been
to Amsterdam during covet where I biked
around with not just bikes in the center
and sure there were less people but the
center itself was still alive things
were happening people were going to
places the prox entering contrast was
completely dead and the killer's name is
Airbnb the name of the game is
short-term rental on an industrial scale
and to add insult to injury it's made to
look all friendly and Casual you get in
touch with Peter from Prague through the
app he meets you shows you his apartment
gives you the keys wishes you a pleasant
stay and leaves what a cool local guy in
reality there are about two dozen Peters
from prog roaming the city all working
for the same Cayman Islands shell
company owned by some Russian or Chinese
oligarch in many cases these oligarchs
with their hard-earned money have bought
at entire residential blocks in the
Prague Center to operate them purely as
airbnbs the friendly casual small-scale
world of short-term rentals almost
immediately became a cold calculating
the large-scale industry and a very
profitable one at that to the point
where landlords can make more money by
turning their rental apartment into a
purely short-term operation instead of
letting it out to people who actually
want to live there by the way BNB stands
for bed and breakfast a type of
accommodation where you share the
property with the owners during your
stay meaning you get a room inside
someone else's place and breakfast in
the morning but that's not efficient
enough as a result 76 of prague's
short-term rentals are full apartments
with nobody living in them long term
where regular people can no longer
afford to live even near the center the
situation is most dire in the Prague old
town where before kovid there were
between 3.5 and 5 000 Airbnb apartments
in the whole of Prague this number was
14 000 Apartments this Reckless pursuit
of profit has reached such ludicrous
levels that before kovid there were 60
more apartment listings for tourists
than listings for prospective tenants
kovit turned the tables however with the
number of prog airbnbs effectively
helding to around 7 000 Apartments
city-wide this is not expected to last
however and the number will be back to
its pre-covered Levels by next season
and this is a big problem Airbnb takes
time thousands of units of the long-term
real estate market creating an
artificial Supply shortage causing
prices to Skyrocket the constant noise
and a noise by drunk tourists make areas
unlivable for long-term tenants who end
up moving out the landlord is then stuck
with an empty apartment paradoxically
located in a less desirable yet
extremely expensive area as less people
want to live there but the mortgage has
to be paid the landlord opts for
short-term rental the unfortunate
logical solution out of control
short-term renting initiates a vicious
cycle in cities more airbnbs mean less
long-term tenants and more tourists this
causes more noise and annoyance which
means even less long-term tenants which
then causes businesses based on
long-term tenants like grocery stores
hairdressers laundromats Etc to close
down those get replaced by souvenir
shops and tourist traps which turns the
area into an urban desert for long-term
tenants which means even less of them
and even more of Airbnb guests and this
is why the pro gold town was completely
empty during covet because almost nobody
lives there anymore it's all a big
open-air Disneyland for tourists and the
locals including me when I live there
are stuck commuting from the edges of
the city every day switching between
three boxes there home transportation in
their workplace not getting to
experience the beautiful Prague Old Town
anymore because there is nothing there
for us for people who actually live in
Prague it's an urban Dead Zone thanks to
short-term rentals flanked by another
Urban Dead Zone caused by prague's worst
Urban freeway this so-called magistrala
so was the solution easy limit or ban
short-term rentals in Amsterdam you can
only let your apartment at the tourist
for 30 days per year while Barcelona
practically banned the practice in the
center the result living healthy City
centers with actual inhabitants in them
oh and while we're at it let's also blow
up the magistrala just like how the
Czech city of boost in Alabama blew up
its Baroque Old Town in the 70s that
being said if you like using Airbnb for
your trips I'm not saying you're a bad
person I just want you to keep in mind
what sort of system you're participating
in as you and thousands of others sleep
comfortably in those trendy Central
studio apartments ready to experience
the city the next day thousands of
locals are out in remote sleeping areas
unable to avoid living in their own City
Airbnb is a prime example of why we need
to regulate things without regulation
all these cutesy personal peer-to-peer
hipster part objects like libertarianism
Risk becoming soulless industrial scale
capitalistic Endeavors with Untold
damage to cities and communities and if
you personally own and operate in Airbnb
please consider letting it out to
long-term tenants instead thank you and
I thank you for watching as well
subscribe to my channel for more and I
also have a patreon if you wish to
support me making such content and I'll
be seeing you next time